[Music]
time now for our morning rounds medical
news of the week when it comes to
colorectal cancer the latest data shows
an overall decline in cases for older
Americans but for those 55 and younger
it's a different story earlier this week
the American Cancer Society published
updated colorectal cancer screening
guidelines for those at average risk in
a major change they now say screenings
should start earlier than previously
suggested here to discuss this and more
is CBS News medical contributor dr.
David agus who joins us bright and early
from Los Angeles David good morning good
morning Anthony so what are the
headlines coming out of this new study
it's pretty bright first of all calling
people over the 50th age of 55 or older
is kind of scary
older Americans but we're seeing this
trend of colon cancer happening in
earlier earlier in younger people you
know I had a case in their 20s of colon
cancer several decades ago that was
unheard of but for some reason there's a
demographic shift and so now their new
recommendations are to get screaming
which is predominantly colonoscopy the
gold standard would happen at age 45
instead of 50 that's a major shift in
this country remember there's still
50,000 people a year dying of colon
cancer which is predominantly
preventable if you have a screening test
you said there's a demographic shift
some reason do we know potentially why
we're seeing this in younger people I
certainly wish I mean it whether it's
that we're larger we're more sedentary
our diets have changed we don't know the
exact reason but we're seeing this shift
and it's rather surprising this increase
and you know a reaction to the increase
is the hopefully that we can reduce
these deaths over 3,000 deaths a year
and people under the age of 50 from
colon cancer so the shift hopefully will
reduce the numbers of death in that
demographic David you mentioned
colonoscopy which is kind of as the gold
standard of testing but there are other
types of testing I mean how do you
decide what to do here there are other
types of testing you know colonoscopy
every 10 years there's sigmoidoscopy
there's the tests where they look for
blood in your stool have it
discussion with your doctor of what's
the right one each of them have risks
and benefits and none of them are
perfect but certainly have one of them
and have the right one based on your
family history and your risk profile to
hopefully prevent this disease alright
our next topic deals with terminally ill
patients and experimental drugs on
Wednesday President Trump signed into
law the right to try act it allows
certain drugs not yet approved by the
Food and Drug Administration to be
administered determinately ill patients
who have run out of other options David
break this legislation down for us a
little further if you could so this is
something that President Trump announced
in his State of the Union address in
January that is that drugs that are not
yet on the market they finished initial
testing what we call phase 1 testing and
at people with end-stage illness so you
know don't have any other standard
treatments to get can get these drugs
right now I give them to patients
routinely with the FDA's permission the
FDA has approved these drugs 99 plus
percent of the time and it's usually
within 24 to 48 hours we can give these
drugs what this new legislation says is
is that we're gonna take the FDA out of
the picture that the individual can
negotiate the doctor and the patient
with the pharmaceutical company and get
the drug without the FDA's involvement
just because people can get the drug
though David it doesn't mean the
pharmaceutical companies necessarily
will be giving them the drug so what are
the obstacles here no question about it
is that I don't think this will change
very much what's going on we routinely
can get drugs we call it compassionate
use in patients who have no other
treatments and pharmaceutical companies
many times do this but this legislation
doesn't mandate the pharmaceutical may
do it and there are a lot of risks for
the pharmaceutical company there could
be side effects the patient can
potentially even sue the pharmaceutical
company and they could take the focus
off of developing the drug and maybe
slow it for other patients and it's
actually costly and so I'm not sure this
legislation is going to do a lot there's
certainly a lot of press or media about
it a lot of hype around it but doesn't
really change the landscape in treating
patients with end-stage disease alright
one last topic David as the weather gets
warmer so does the urge to spend time
side but are you paying enough attention
to protecting your skin prolonged an
unprotected exposure to the Sun could
lead to melanoma the most dangerous form
of skin cancer according to the American
Cancer Society more than 91 thousand new
cases of melanoma will be diagnosed this
year alone a majority will involve men
accounting for a little over fifty five
thousand of these cases so some basic
ideas that people should keep in mind to
just prevent any damage from the Sun not
just melanoma so UVA UVB lights from the
Sun can damage skin wear sunscreen
especially between the hours of 10:00
and 4:00 a cloudy day UV light goes
right through the clouds so it doesn't
matter whether it's cloudy or it's sunny
wear sunscreen and protection the best
thing above sunscreen is wear long
sleeve cotton shirts wear a hat try to
keep your skin out of that Sun you will
thank yourself years two decades down
the road because you'll prevent skin
cancer dr. David agus thanks so much for
being with us this morning